[Musique]
nouvelle édition du 78 tours sur tv 78
merci de nous rejoindre une nouvelle
fois pour découvrir les richesses du
département nous ferons comme chaque
mois de nombreuses les escales dans les
yvelines nous irons notamment à
versailles découvrir son os motech un
lieu unique aux mille et une senteurs un
lieu chargé d'histoire également aurait
pu inviter originaire de trappes à bout
originaire du mali arrivé en france très
jeune il a développé son propre courant
musical riche de son parcours résolument
optimiste la fri pop son nouvel album
est attendu pour le mois de mai est en
plateau pour m'accompagner mathilde
offre en kumité denis d'euros bienvenue
à tous les deux michael vous allez nous
emmener à croissy-sur-seine tout à l'air
tout à l'heure effectivement à
croissy-sur-seine une exposition qui
s'appelle cabale ça vous dit pas
forcément grand chose mais c'est pour
les tout petits
ça parle de cavale doit la série k maro
quelques images déjà et mathilde avec
vous vous allez faire un nous faire
faire un circuit dans le département des
yvelines circuit gourmand pâques c'est
dans quelques jours j'ai sélectionné
trois chocolatier yvelinois al'approche
de pâques donc une petite sélection pour
pour commencer
à telus est à déguster à voit la
curiosité pour les papilles
c'est surprenant puisqu'on parle de
gourmandise alors justement commençons à
cette émission avec le palmarès du guide
michelin l'édition 2022 a rendu son
verdict cette étoile et dans les
yvelines c'est une charge nous a préparé
un petit récapitulatif
[Musique]
où
vous
m
[Musique]
où
mon
m
[Musique]
où
oh
m
[Musique]
oh
il
je
[Musique]
e
à
[Musique]
m
voilà pour les sept étoiles et du
département les connaissez déjà vous les
avez testé quelques heures effectivement
j'ai pu tester la table des blu qui est
à dampierre c'est bien ça si j'ai bien
lu ma si vous êtes allé
youri stable des boulots
et voilà quelques ordres dans aussi très
long palace aussi j'avais un cocktail
autres n ont pas lâchés au gordon ramsay
c'était pas mal vous validez les étoiles
valide très bien pour ce 78 ans nous
allons à présent faire une escale à
trappes avec notre invité à boubacar
doumbia qui va nous rejoindre vous le
connaissez sous son nom d'artiste à bout
nous recevons donc à présent en plateau
à bout bienvenue bonjour ultra c'est
d'avoir accepté l'invitation merci de
l'invitation c'est un plaisir pour moi
que de vous retrouver ici quand ça fait
assez longtemps qu'on ne vous avait pas
vu sur notre antenne et pourtant vous
êtes suivi dès le début de votre
carrière on a vu votre évolution même
alors justement pour ceux qui étaient là
et puis ceux qui vont vous découvrez on
va regarder un extrait d'un de vos
premiers morceaux justement ok tout
faire
les armes c'est ma femme je ne donnerai
pas la guerre l'amour et mahler mais
somme toute une armée de révolte est
d'ailleurs un seul ce kg en lutte contre
l'injustice ou moins fermés micro c'est
ma lutte peut-être ne l'entend pas moi
même je ne m'attends pas à compter sur
toi je dois pas la route est longue sur
les chemins de la vérité avec les miens
a jamais présents pour féliciter la
galère
elle est ma banque elle est
abou et son offre hip hop c'est le nom
du courant que vous allez développer on
va revenir sur tout ça c'était l'un de
vos premiers morceaux il ya presque une
dizaine d'années effectivement m abbas a
fait dix ans à peu près quoi ouais j'en
reviens sur votre parcours originaire de
ma bague bamako pardon vous rejoignez la
france avec votre famille votre père
elle vers 2 2 3 ans tout à fait je fais
le résume éducation stricte valeur
travail qui est mise en avant vous
devenez ingénieur informatique sauf que
vous avez d'autres aspirations la
musique la fibre artistique
quel est le déclic et comment se passe
ce changement de carrière le déclic je
dirais que c'est là depuis un moment en
tout cas ça me paraît rôdé vraiment moi
dès que je suis arrivé j'avais envie de
chanter m'exprimer en tout cas au niveau
de la musique mais le déclic il est
vraiment arrivé en
2001 ou là donc je travaillais en tant
qu ingénieur informatique effectivement
et où j'ai carrément démissionné de la
société j'avais vraiment un bon poste
j'avais un très bon salaire mais à cette
époque là je me suis rendu compte que
après il ya des événements aussi qui
sont passé à la même période mais je me
suis rendu compte que si je le faisais
pas à ce moment précis je ne le ferai
jamais donc j'ai décidé de démissionner
ça a été très difficile là pendant les
premiers mois mais franchement
lorsqu'on va vraiment pris pour un fou
votre situation tu démissionnes de ça
c'était peut-être réfléchi mais au
contraire moi je me sentais comme ça ça
a été difficile mais vraiment je
regrette pas et je suis vraiment content
que de l'avoir fait parce que c'est des
décisions qui sont difficiles à prendre
c'est vrai mais en même temps voilà
c'est quelque chose qui pour moi était
important pour ma vie que d'aller vers
le sens que je souhaitais pour l quoi
donc aucun regret il faut dire qu'elle
est libre artistique tout de même dans
la famille on l'a déjà dit je leur
précise et votre frère c'est issa
doumbia plus poursuit sa carrière aussi
sur scène et au cinéma parlons musique
vous avez voulu développer donc aussi
votre propre courant et ce courant c'est
la fri pop tout à fait l'afrique on en a
entendu un extrait et comment vous le
définissez secours alors la fri pop donc
ça change pas ça évolue mais c'est
toujours vraiment un mélange de racines
africaines de hip-hop et de culture
populaire comme je dis c'est pas
vraiment durable moi je chante toujours
en français et en bambara sur des beats
parfois que son hip hop d'autres un peu
plus sale ça c'est vraiment mélange
entre all world music et musiques
urbaines mais vraiment l'idée c'est d'y
intégrer des valeurs la première c'est
d'une part te faire penser tout en te
faisant danser il y aura toujours
vraiment un message de dents que ce soit
des titres qu'ils soient festifs ou un
peu plus profond il y aura toujours un
message mais un message qui pousse vers
la vision du verre à moitié plein mais
également défendre ses valeurs c'est
qu'ils sont peu importe la couleur de
peau sa classe sociale ou ta religion
c'est vraiment une couleur d'esprit et
des valeurs positives que j'essaie de
diffuser au travers de ma musique ancrée
justement ce mouvement encore toujours
optimiste toujours toujours ses skis et
fédérateur
plusieurs albums plusieurs sortir votre
site internet va s'afficher pour tous
ceux qui voudraient suivre les liens
pour pour écouter et découvrir votre
univers il est plusieurs collaborations
que ce soit en france au mali aussi
voilà il ya vraiment cette connexion
entre ces deux pays vaut deux pays tout
à fait le mali mon pays de naissance de
coeur et la france mon pays d'accueil de
coeur également donc moi vraiment par
rapport à cette musique j'essaie d'être
un pont entre ces deux continents
l'europe et l'afrique et en particulier
le mali et la france pour vraiment dire
que j'essaie de faire des choses de par
mes actes mais parole est ce que
j'essaie de véhicules et c'est pour
vraiment donné l'envi aux autres de
découvrir le mali de ladoux moi je viens
mais également essayé de faire en sorte
de développer demain des artistes au
mali et essayer de les faire émarger au
travers de l'europe donc non vraiment
j'ai c'est en tout cas d'être ce vecteur
ce pont culturel entre nos deux pays
quoi vous avez fondé aussi votre propre
société pour développer votre activité
ayez un nouvel album qui va sortir
qu'être préparation c'est au moins de
mai voilà donc là ça y est il est
terminée donc l'album ses affluents
spirit héritage donc
il a déjà été mis en prévente depuis le
13 mars dernier c'est à dire que là en
fait j'ai on adopter une stratégie est
manager ce qui est de sortir un titre
toutes les semaines donc j'ai cette
petite qui vont sortir en fait en
prévente toutes les semaines depuis le
13 mars jusqu'au 29 avril ensuite on
s'arrête il ya deux semaines qui vont
passer et l'a donc y aura l'album et ses
15 titres qui seront au public quoi ça
va leur appartenir à partir de là
pendant la période du confinement vous
avez été actif aussi vous avez tourné un
petit clip web on va peut-être un
extrait du comme savoir parler continuer
à discuter ensuite
ma première blessure
ces marchés
pense
c'est
pour m
bonjour
extrait du nouvel album a bien bien
arriver bientôt le 13 mai je cherchais
la date en même temps elle dabou donc
toujours avec ce style là trip hop
dizaine d'années de carrière maintenant
est ce qu'il ya une évolution oui je
pense que si vraiment il ya une
évolution autant pour moi par rapport à
ça reste toujours dans la même lignée de
ce que j'essaie de diffuser en termes de
valeur vraiment mais à une évolution
autant au niveau des nouveautés qui
arrivent que vous allez découvrir toute
façon ça reste dans la lignée mais c'est
vrai que c'est beaucoup plus ouvert
encore aujourd'hui
par rapport au thème par rapport à la
musicalité par rapport aux beats même
j'essaie d'amener une nouvelle vraiment
couleurs c'est à dire rester dans mon
afrique poc mais ne pas changer mais
évoluer vraiment donc on garde vraiment
l'adn de valeurs positives partager
vraiment des bonnes choses entre nous et
et montrer que la mixité la différence
surtout est une force dont que c'est ce
qu'il faut comprendre entre nous mais
aussi dénoncé parfois parce que dans une
famille on peut aussi se dire la vérité
donc dire ce qui ne va pas et essai
suite à ça de trouver des solutions pour
avancer ensemble pour un avenir meilleur
ensemble corps mais quand vous on va pas
parler de politique en plus ya des
élections en ce moment mais l on a senti
quand même ces dernières semaines et ces
derniers mois qu'on était plus dans le
cadre de la division que de l'unité en
tant qu'humain aussi ça vous affecte
bien sûr ça m'affecte bien sûr que ça
m'affecte maintenant je pense que chacun
d'entre nous de notre côté en quelques
pas on est des politiques de par les
valeurs de par nos discussions de parce
qu'on va défendre ce à quoi on croit
donc je pense que mon âne nous tous
notre part a à faire dans ce combat je
dirai qui et de nous prouver à tous que
voilà l'essentiel c'est d'être ensemble
essayer de trouver des solutions qui
nous font avancer ensemble parce qu'on
est sur cette même planète on est tous
des humains peu importe où encore une
fois notre couleur de peau classes
sociales aux religions
le but de chaque injustement cessé de
prospérer faire évoluer sa famille
grandir et et cultiver l'amour autour de
nous donc je pense qu on est chacun des
politiques à notre niveau moi c'est au
niveau de la culture essayez de par mes
messages justement nous montrer que le
ver vraiment il peut être tout le temps
à moitié plein toujours trouver une
bonne solution ou vraiment un bon
message ou une bonne direction par
rapport à ce qui nous est arrivé
l'expérience à vous tirer à free pop
tirer music.com c'est le site internet
sur lequel on peut découvrir tout autre
univers est ce qu'il y à des concerts
aussi à venir pour accompagner la sortie
de l'album au mois de mai alors il va y
avoir des concerts pour l'instant c'est
pas encore arrêtée parce que c'est vrai
qu'on est en phase de recherche
également
des vraiment un tourneur ou un booker
qui va vraiment prendre la grosse tâche
de la scène parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
prêts par rapport à ça donc on est en
train de chercher celle de notre côté il
ya des scènes qui vont arriver mais qui
sont pas encore de leur côté même verrue
en terme de date mais c'est vrai qu'on
est inscrit à plein plein d'événements
qui devrait arriver prochainement mais
j'aurai ainsi ce qu'on est vraiment en
train de chercher une personne
additionner un autre équipe qui est un
bouquet rond un tourneur pour pouvoir
justement sur scène démontrer ce que la
fri pop et quoi vraiment parce que
l'essence c'est vraiment la scène pour -
co et puis la scène vous la connaissez
bien on peut juste revenir pour conclure
sur la première partie à la merise nafa
blondy
et donc première partie d'alpha blondy
c'était extraordinaire vraiment c'est un
moment magique public extraordinaire
alpha blondy vraiment quelqu'un de
humble très à l'écouté qui donne son
soutien de la force vraiment donc j'ai
passé vraiment un bon moment des changes
avec un public était à l'ecoute
réceptifs et qui m'a vraiment redonné de
la force et même moi ça m'a donné
beaucoup de confiance par rapport à ce
que j'ai je suis en train de proposer
pour dire que voilà c'est vraiment
l'endroit il faut que je sois quoi sur
la scène pour proposer ce message et ce
show à la rencontre de la fripouille
quoi merci beaucoup à vous d'être venu
en place et hop on espère pouvoir
bientôt avec d'aussi jolies lunettes
fallait forcément que je le dise depuis
tout à l'heure
c'est beaucoup avouent prochainement sur
terre et 70 à très bientôt merci
[Musique]
on va maintenant parler d'une exposition
avec vous michael vous êtes venu sans
vos lunettes c'est à courcy sur scène
c'est jusqu'au 6 novembre j'adore les
lunettes de bourg on va lui demander de
vous les laisser pour la prochaine
émission ça touche à noyer cette
exposition cabane c'est tout nouveau
s'est ouvert depuis fin février dernier
à croissy-sur-seine imaginé un parcours
sur plusieurs scènes avec une dizaine de
cabanes de toutes tailles de toutes les
couleurs tout cela il des matériaux du
quotidien
on retrouve par exemple une cabane avec
des livres des cabanes avec des
bonbonnes d'eau ou encore des miroirs à
l'intérieur objectif plaire aux enfants
de 2 à 7 on écoute le maire de la
commune au micro de tv 68 en fait c'est
tout qui fait pour que le petit enfant
puisse avoir de l'autonomie puissent
pouvoir réfléchir puissent pouvoir se
projeter et construire son monde à lui
loin des parents dans des cabanes qu'il
construit lui même cette exposition a
déjà fait parler d'elle a été présenté
en 2020 à la cité des sciences et de
l'industrie à la villette à paris et a
réuni plus de 220 mille visiteurs et
c'est la première fois qu'elle s'exporte
on écoute le maire de la commune georges
et davin il est évidemment très heureux
de ce partenariat
la cité des sciences et quand quelque
chose de très connus reconnus qui est
important pour les enfants en même temps
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler la base
arrière de la cité des sciences dans
deux villes plus petites puisque c'est
la première fois qu'ils s'exportent en
dehors de la villette et qui vont dans
une ville et qu'ils ont choisi le coin
si sur scène
j'aime beaucoup la cabane livre moi elle
à votre préférée c'est là qu'elle a la
livre était pas mal mais sinon j'ai
beaucoup aimé les miroirs moi car ça va
jouer un peu gênant
j'ai pas pu non plus j'avais un timing à
respecter au niveau du reportage mais
j'aurais pu y passer une heure en face
il une ou deux heures est-ce qu'il ya du
monde c'est un succès alors au total
l'exposition a déjà attiré plus de 2200
à visiteurs au château chan lauriers
depuis son lancement un bon chiffre
selon la mairie on va écouter les
réactions à la fin de la visite qui
durent en général deux heures
pompe inficolor il faut payer un prix et
demi dans laquelle m moi je trouve ça
super autant pour les petites pour les
grands parce qu'on peut aussi les grands
à l'aidant dans les cabanes donc c'est
c'est bien parce qu'il ya plein de
stimulation ils peuvent manipuler
il ya des il ya des cabanes avec plein
de clins de glace partout on sent un
petit peu dans un univers fantastique et
on voit pas le temps passer non c'est
vraiment une super expo pour les petits
et les grands il faudrait une jolie par
contre elle il adore parce qu'on peut
faire des petits trucs elle l'a pas je
la trouve pas moche elle à moi je la
trouve belle
mais celle là je la trouve très belle
alors si on veut accrocher détruire
contre s allonger
[Musique]
en fait elle les aime toutes toutes les
cabanes sais j'ai préféré ce ses
préférées ce n est pas moi j'ai pas
beaucoup
l'aurez compris wilfrid ce rendez vous
plaît beaucoup aux enfants à si vous
voulez la découvrir cette exposition est
installée au château chaîne auriez
jusqu'au 6 novembre avant d'être
remplacé par une exposition sur les
chiens et les chats en fin d'année je
pense que ça pourrait vous plaire c'est
autre chose à cette fois-ci ouais c'est
pas trop moche mathilde ça pouvait aussi
pour aller faire une grande journée
entreprises là bas pourquoi pas aussi à
les prochaines escales dans les yvelines
il va falloir ouvrir grand ses narines
votre nez sera mis à contribution justin
brasier va nous faire découvrir
l'osmothèque de versailles un lieu
unique conservatoire du parfum et on se
retrouve juste après un plateau
[Musique]
m
pour ce nouveau volet patrimoine je vous
emmène au coeur de l'osmothèque un
conservatoire international de parfum
est inaugurée par jean pierre léaud avec
un groupe de parfumeurs passionnés ce
lieu unique au monde est implantée à
versailles dans les locaux de l'itie
pcaa anne-cécile point directrice
déléguée de l'osmothèque et isabelle
chassot présidente du comité
scientifique et nous ont donné rendez
vous pour une visite sur mesure c'est
parti
[Musique]
les trois grandes missions de
l'osmothèque sont la plus importante la
préservation de ce patrimoine donc ça
c'est la collection de parfums de
l'osmothèque ensuite nous avons une
partie médiation culturelle donc nous
transmettons nous faisons connaître nous
faisant découvrir ou redécouvrir les
trésors et les chefs-d'oeuvre du
patrimoine de la parfumerie et enfin
nous avons un programme de recherche qui
nous permet de faire avancer la
connaissance que l'on a de l'histoire du
parfum c'est un lieu on retrouve
l'émotion on a connu avec certains
parfums porté par des gens qu'on a aimé
le parfum est un art donc nous
conservons une histoire de cet art à
travers les parfums essais on vient à le
smau tech sentir des parfums comme on va
dans un musée voir des tableaux ou des
sculptures c'est tout à fait la même
démarche
le fruit défendu doubi gants ou encore
crêpe de chine de coty ici on peut
retrouver près de 850 parfums a disparu
et parmi eux des trésors du passé
on a par exemple parfum royal qui datent
du premier siècle après j y crée en tout
cas on la refait à partir d'une recette
de pline l'ancien qui est donc au 1er
siècle après jésus-christ on a fait une
interprétation c'est une exception dans
la collection de l'osmothèque et ça vous
donne une idée de ce que pouvait sentir
un romain sans doute d'une classe aisée
de cette époque là c'est un parfum
extrêmement puissant qui contient
beaucoup de cannelle qui contient 27
ingrédients et qui
est très différent de ce qu'on pouvait
de ce qu'on peut sentir actuellement
dans une parfumerie on n'a pas aussi par
exemple l'eau de la reine de hongrie qui
date soit disant du 14e siècle est sans
doute la recette est sans doute un peu
plus ancienne mais c'est en tout cas un
des premiers parfums fait avec de
l'alcool
[Musique]
où
plus de cinq mille parfums sont
conservés ici et justement on va les
découvrir ces conditions de conservation
dans la cave un endroit inaccessible au
public
donc ici nous conservons leaf les
parfums dans des
à l'abri de trois ennemis qui sont la
lumière donc nous mettons les parfums
dans des flacons en verre sombre anti-uv
les variations de température donc nous
les conservons toute l'année à 12 degrés
pour éviter les effets thermiques et
nous les protégeons aussi de l'oxygène
qui est un ennemi du parfum et donc pour
cela nous mettons à chaque fois que nous
prélevons dans une dans un flacon que
nous appelons flacon mer un gaz plus
lourd que l'air qui vient assurer une
sorte de couche de protection
[Musique]
montrez ce parfum qui fait qui a fêté
ses 100 ans donc là on est sur une
version d'émeraude re pesé par
un os mottez caire pour que nous
puissions encore aujourd'hui 100 ans
après sentir ce parfum tels que françois
coty l'a rêvé et la proposer aux femmes
en 1921 le site est accessible sur
rendez-vous ou via des découverte
olfactive plus d'informations sur le
site de l'osmothèque
merci justin pour cette nouvelle
découverte du patrimoine yvelinois
pâques approche ce n'est pas une grande
nouvelle ce n'est pas une révélation et
beaucoup de polémiques un an autour de
chocolat qu'il vaut mieux éviter de
consommer en revanche vous nous avez
sélectionné quelques chocolatier
yvelinois et là c'est 100% safe oui j'ai
sélectionné trois chocolatier yvelinois
pour consommer local on commence par le
premier il s'agit d'un grand chef
pâtissier il tenait un magasin de
caramel sur paris dans lequel elle a
créé quelques unes des meilleures
pâtisseries de la capitale à cause ou
grâce du coc vide il a décidé de se
délocaliser et de venir s'installer dans
les yvelines il a fondé l'atelier gâteau
alors est ce que vous savez de qui je
parle sans prétention c'est nicolas il
était venu en plateau vous faire
déguster sur sa vie j'ai un trou de
mémoire bâtiment il s'agit de nicolas
hâle irwin et donc il est situé à
guyancourt et à versailles et même si la
pâtisserie représente sa marque de
fabrique il confectionne aussi des
chocolats sont très chauds dit oui pour
ce faire que vous pouvez trouver des
chocolats classiques comme des poussins
pour les petits eux mais aussi voilà des
chocolats pour un peu plus extravagants
comme le dark lapin le super confond
encore le lapin vasin les prix vont de 4
à 30 euros autres chocolatiers local
l'atelier olivier roy d'or installé
depuis vingt ans à voisins le bretonneux
il propose une large gamme de chocolats
son atelier se situe juste derrière sa
boutique où il transforme sur place des
chocolats provenant du mexique du
venezuela ou encore de cuba là aussi les
gourmands pourront retrouver des
chocolats classiques comme des poules
des lapins des oeufs mais aussi des
chocolats un peu plus fantaisistes comme
des oeufs marvel des dinosaures ou
encore des poissons qui rate ce marvel
d'accord
j'aime beaucoup le dinosaure aussi vrai
mon coeur balance entre le lapin crétin
dans un dinosaure là les prix sont aux
alentours de 10 à 30 euros et enfin
chocolaterie familiale installée à maule
depuis 1974 les chocolats colas ont tout
se fait de manière artisanale c'est
hélène qui a repris la chocolaterie de
ses parents il n'y a maintenant 27 ans
tous les ans pour pâques l avant un
nouveau thème cette année cette
technique avec les impressionnistes l
écoute
des impressionnistes qu'on avait des
envies de plein air avec ce poète le
pont vinh et donc nous avons beaucoup
sont inspirés les autres mais
on a d'autres il
est donc en plus de ses yeux aux
paysages bucoliques les chocolats colas
ont également imaginé 17 de pin de pique
nique pardon entièrement comestible
comestibles pardon avec des glacières
des thermos ou encore des chapeaux de
paille a choisi je n'ai même pas pu
nous on aime le travail et sur des rangs
du
tiers et les dents apprécient aussi ce
sera fait dans les types ont aperçu de
leurs personnes issues de formations
africain
l'a
effectivement certains employés ont fait
l'école des beaux-arts et réalisons que
maintenant un des peintures sur des
chocolats tout est comestible bien
entendu la peinture est créée grâce à du
chocolat blanc du beurre de cacao et des
pigments alimentaire et là les chocolats
vont de 6 euros à 94 euros quand même
surtout plus classique cette fois ci
dans ma préférence ça reste finalement
le dinosaure moi je vote pour le
dinosaure moi je vois pour tout
simplement que ça se mange vous mettez
pour tout s'effondre merci le mois
prochain on aura pas manger trop de
chocolat et qu'on réussira être présent
pour la prochaine émission 78 tours est
terminée pour ce mois ci on se retrouve
donc le mois prochain pour de nouvelles
escales dans le département merci à vous
deux
[Musique]